et l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle sur le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 donc il y a
des explications de vote de 5 minutes
avec un orateur par groupe le premier
orateur sera Monsieur Philippe lottiau
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous voici de nouveau autour
du projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques 2022-2027 un texte
qui aurait été profondément amendé dans
cette hémicycle tout d'abord avec
différents ajouts sur un objectif de
légère baisse des dépenses fiscales des
engagements en termes de transition
écologique ou une volonté de
rationalisation de l'action des
opérateurs de l'État il a eu surtout la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
d'articles que nous ne regretterons pas
il en est ainsi de l'article 11 sur le
plafond des autorisations d'emploi de
détails de ces opérateurs qui a posé une
règle unique à des situations
potentiellement très différentes de
l'article 12 qui posait pour trois ans
les plafonds de crédit des missions du
budget général de l'État sans réel
réflexion à l'appui sur le contenu des
dépenses considérées et sur les voies
moyen de les réduire ou à l'inverse la
nécessité de les augmenter des articles
13 16 et 23 qui portaient à la fois des
réductions des concours financiers de
l'État aux collectivité locale et qui
surtout les faisait rentrer dans un
système contraignant de baisse des
dépenses toujours en euros courant
inadaptés contraire à l'esprit de la
décentralisation et qui plus est inutile
dans la mesure où il n'est pas besoin de
forcer des collectivités pour qu'elle
prête attention à la limitation de leur
dépense et enfin des articles 17 18 et
19 sur les objectifs en matière de
dépenses des régimes de sécurité sociale
là encore pas forcément adapté à la
situation actuelle et aux besoins et qui
anticipaient le vote du PLFSS malgré ces
suppressions ce texte demeur
insatisfaisant et notamment son article
premier qui approuve un rapport annexé
de présentation des objectifs et de la
trajectoire prévue souffrant de trois
termes majeures tout d'abord il s'agit
encore d'un exercice d'autosatisfaction
nous devrions pourtant y être habitués
vous êtes les plus beaux les plus forts
les plus intelligents vous nous le dites
régulièrement et quand vous nous le
dites pas vous le pensez tellement fort
que c'est tout comme et bien voyez-vous
au risque de vous décevoir nous
n'arrivons pas à le croire
deuxièmement vos perspectives s'appuient
sur des prévisions de croissance et
d'inflation que de nombreuses
institutions considèrent très optimistes
pour ne pas dire irréaliste en outre
vous citez à l'appui de vos chiffres un
ensemble de réformes qui n'ont pas été
votées par le Parlement et dont les
contours de Lyon même pas été présentés
de la dire que vous faites fille de la
représentation nationale il n'y a qu'un
pas que je franchirai volontiers si vous
aviez utilisé le 49-3 en fait vous l'a
utilisé deux fois
enfin vous considérez comme nul et non
avenue les risques de crise économique
induits par la hausse du coût de
l'énergie et des matières premières un
risque qui pèse tout particulièrement
sur les TPE et les PME qui doivent
parallèlement rembourser leur PGE et
aussi sur le secteur clé du bâtiment
particulièrement fragilisé avec un recul
important de la construction vous voulez
donner l'impression d'un ciel dégagé
pour ma part j'aurais tendance à
paraphraser Clint Eastwood quand je suis
dans un tunnel et que je vois de la
lumière au bout avec vous je serai
toujours que ce soit un train qui arrive
en face alors évidemment
nous ne pourrons voter ce texte même si
les moins imparfait qu'au début
alors je sais vous allez jouer le coeur
des vierges et pleurer comment il n'y a
pas de programmation quelle horreur
qu'allons de devenir et notre
crédibilité sur ce point je voudrais
dire deux choses tout d'abord mieux vaut
peut-être dans le court terme pas de
programmation qu'une programmation
factice dont le seul objet serait
complet à l'Union européenne car
n'oublions pas que c'est quand même cela
le but présenter à la commission un joli
document pour que monsieur Macron passe
pour un bon élève auprès sa chair Ursula
vanderlione il faudra d'ailleurs qu'on
explique de quel droit celles-ci semble
de plus en plus présidé au destinés de
notre pays en toute est à cause ce
document est un symbole supplémentaire
de notre père de souveraineté au profit
de l'Union européenne
et puis enfin comment nous satisfaire
d'une programmation qui continue à nous
ranger dans les cinq années à venir
comme un pays recordman des prélèvements
obligatoires des déficits publics et de
la dette car en dehors des prix
réalistes votre programmation est
insatisfaisante elle devrait tenir
compte des défis qui sont les nôtres
tout ceci en réduisant le déficit public
et le poids des prélèvements
obligatoires par la fin de certaines
gajies liées à dire liées à l'idéologie
européiste libre-échangiste et
immigrationnistes qui nous mènent à la
dérive de cela nous aurons pu dialoguer
car vous saviez dès le passage en
commission que ce texte ne saurait être
adopté en l'état mais vous n'avez pas
fait le choix vous variez de dialogue
mais pour vous le dialogue c'est en fait
une tragique Mehdi en 5 actes premier
acte vous expliquez dans ton dogs que
vous avez décidé deuxième acte vous
écoutez dernière condescendant vos
contradicteurs troisième acte vous leur
expliquez qu'ils n'ont rien compris
parce que vous avez forcément raison
quatrième acte vous faites ce que vous
voulez quoi qu'on vous ai dit cinquième
acte éventuel si vous ne pouvez pas
faire ce que vous voulez
recours aux 49-3 écrit à
l'irresponsabilité de ceux qui osent ne
pas être d'accord avec vous fin de la
pièce voilà votre vision du dialogue
mais et ce texte me démontre les
ressorts sont désormais visibles car la
suffisance de vos discours ne serait
infiniment masquée l'insuffisance de vos
résultats je vous remercie un collègue
la parole est à Charlotte Leduc pour le
groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général collègue nous sommes
aujourd'hui appelés à nous prononcer sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour la période 2023 2027 et
je ne vais pas faire durer le suspense
longtemps notre groupe combat cette loi
depuis son premier passage en commission
malgré nos amendements malgré le rejet
de ce texte par la commission des
finances malgré la suppression de 8 des
26 articles du projet par cette
hémicycle le gouvernement persiste et ne
change pas de cap et bien nous aussi
nous persistons et signons en vous
proposant chers collègues de rejeter ce
texte nous l'avons dit à maintes
reprises ce texte ne fait que programmer
l'austérité pour les 5 années à venir en
prévoyant de contenir la croissance des
dépenses publiques à 0,6% par an soit
bien moins que la croissance
tendancielle des dépenses publiques qui
s'établit à 1,35% par an le gouvernement
fait le choix de la dégradation
contenu de nos services publics déjà
exangs quelle irresponsabilité à l'heure
où les me ou les immenses défis
climatiques géopolitiques et sociaux qui
se dressent devant nous devrait nous
conduire à des investissements publics
d'ampleur dans l'intérêt du plus grand
nombre la semaine dernière vous avez
amorcé un mauvais feuilleton
anti-démocratique nous avons subi deux
49-3 en moins de 48 heures je parle de
feuilleton car ce sont les mots même de
la première ministre 49-3 deuxième
épisode prononcer à l'entrée de
l'Assemblée nationale et on le sait
d'autres épisodes suivront rapidement à
la chaîne sur les textes budgétaires
comme un mauvais feuilleton dont la fin
de chaque épisode est connue et mauvaise
parce que votre problème c'est que vous
ne maîtrisez pas le scénario de votre
feuilleton le décor a changé les
actrices et les acteurs font de la
rébellion refusent d'être de simples
figurants réécrivent les dialogues et ça
ça ne vous plaît pas alors on baisse le
rideau 49-3
mais quel dommage pour vous dans
l'épisode loi de programmation des
finances publiques vous n'avez pas la
main pas de 49,3 à gaspiller sur ce
texte car celui-là vous souhaitez le
garder sous la main prêt à être dégainé
pour passer en force votre réforme des
retraites dont personne ne veut
mais quelle pas de 49-3 donc sur ce
texte que ce soit en commission des
finances ou en séance nous avons eu la
possibilité de dialoguer d'amander de
rejeter une partie de votre copie nous
le savons vous le savez vous n'avez pas
de majorité pour faire passer ce texte
vous n'avez pas de majorité pour
corseter la politique budgétaire du pays
pour les 5 années à venir et imposer
votre objectif dépassé de retour au
sacro-saint 3% de déficit à l'horizon
2027 parce que c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit d'un rejet sur le fond sur votre
idéologie austéritaire et non pas d'une
posture comme vous le laissez entendre
mais vous continuez dans le déni le plus
complet vous avez justifié votre usage
du 49,3 sur le PLF par l'absence de
majorité alternative à la vôtre pourtant
le rejet de 8 des 26 articles de ce
texte par notre assemblée montre bien
une chose vous n'êtes pas majoritaire
quand nous refusons majoritairement dans
cette hémicycle l'article 13 de votre
projet qui plafonnait les concours
financiers de l'État aux collectivité
territoriales nous députés de la nuque
disons NON à l'austérité quand nous
rejetons majoritairement l'article 23
qui prévoyait de contraindre ces mêmes
collectivités locales à la réduction de
leur budget de fonctionnement d'ici 2027
nous députés de la nuque disons non à
l'austérité quand nous rejetons
l'article 11 qui contraignait fortement
les possibilités de recrutement de
nouveaux agents publics si le besoin
s'en fait sentir nous députés de la
nuque disons non à l'austérité quand
enfin nous supprimons majoritairement
vos articles 17 18 et 19 qui prévoyaient
de faire des économies sur les dépenses
d'assurance maladie nous disons non et
encore non à votre stérilité mortifère
alors à quoi sert désormais votre projet
de loi maintenant que nous en avons
rejeté la plupart des articles
emblématiques à rien ou à pas grand
chose ce n'est plus qu'un texte bancal
des tricoté mais qui reste déprimant
dans sa réclamation mécanique d'une
austérité inconséquente et absurde ce
projet est déjà caduque il l'était dès
le départ car rappelons-le il s'appuie
sur des hypothèses macroéconomiques
fantaisistes tant en termes de
croissance que d'inflation pour les
années à venir oui une autre loi de
programmation des finances publiques
était possible si vous aviez écouté nos
mises en garde peut-être auriez-vous
revu votre copie si vous nous aviez
proposé un texte qui programme les cinq
années à venir en partant des besoins du
peuple et en planifiant résolument la
bifurcation écologique dont l'humanité a
besoin alors vous auriez pu trouver une
majorité d'idées pour faire voter votre
texte mais nous avons proposé tant
d'amendements pour sortir de l'austérité
pour réamérer réarmer nos services
publics face aux défis collectifs qui
nous attendent ou encore pour faire en
sorte que le retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire soit obtenu par un
renforcement de la progressivité fiscale
et non par des économies qui pénalisent
plus fragile vous ne nous avez pas
écouté vous nous avez moqué des
considérés en nous présentant comme
irresponsable aujourd'hui ce sont vous
les irresponsables qui seuls sans
majorité continuer à foncer droit dans
le mur dans l'inaction sociale et
climatique avec un enthousiasme hautain
et une orgueilleuse certitude c'est
pourquoi nous voterons contre ce texte
et nous vous invitons chers collègues à
le rejeter avec nous je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Véronique louvagy
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 2027 était très
attendu par tous ceux qui se préoccupent
de l'État très alarmant de nos comptes
publics et selon ton plus que la
précédente loi de programmation des
finances publiques votée au début du
quinquennat précédent n'a jamais été
respecté par le gouvernement et la
majorité en marche qui se sont écartés
dans des proportions jamais connues
jusqu'à lors une loi de programmation
des finances publiques a une importance
considérable puisqu'elle définit une
trajectoire pour nos finances publiques
au cours des cinq prochaines années elle
fixe le cap à venir et le chemin à
suivre pour atteindre ses objectifs
préalablement définis
au vu de l'importance des enjeux cette
loi te programmation aurait donc dû
avoir un impact déterminant et traduire
une réelle volonté politique de
s'attaquer enfin au redressement de nos
finances publiques et d'en finir avec le
désolant triptyque français des 3D dès
comme dette d comme déficits et des
comme des pensées la situation vous ne
l'ignorez pas est extrêmement critique
puisque la France à l'auto de dépenses
publiques le plus élevé d'Europe est
fait partie des cinq pays d'Europe dont
la dette dépassent les 100% de PIB mais
là ce projet de loi de programmation
constitue une énième occasion manquée et
se révèle extrêmement décevant tant il
nous confirme que le gouvernement n'a
toujours pas pris conscience de
l'impérius nécessité pour la France de
se désendetter quand notre charge de la
dette explose à ce point et rend notre
dette quasi insoutenable la
responsabilité impose de prendre enfin
ce problème à bras le corps et d'en
faire une priorité politique or monsieur
le ministre nous savons tous que le
redressement des comptes publics exige
du courage et impose beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts mais si le dès le début de la
législature vous ne donnez aucune
ambition ou si vous témoignez de si peu
de volonté alors comment croire que nous
pourrons redresser la barre d'ici 5 ans
même l'eau conseil des finances
publiques déplore une trajectoire de
finance publique peut ambitieuse
notamment au regard des engagements
européens de la France et regrettent un
redressement des finances publiques
insuffisantes rendez-vous compte que la
réduction de notre déficit est repoussée
à 2027 pas dans un an pas dans deux ans
pas même dans trois ans mais dans
seulement 5 ans autant dire une éternité
alors que les taux d'intérêt remontent à
vitesse grand V pour dépasser les deux
et demi pour cent à titre indicatif
notre déficit est prévu à 5% du PIB en
2023 contre 1,5% en Allemagne et 3% en
moyenne dans la zone euro mais pire
encore cette loi de programmation est
bâtie sur des hypothèses que tous les
instituts sérieux jugent complètement
irréaliste
pour autant au-delà de leur critique de
leur mise en garde les députés les
républicains ont été forces de
propositions dans l'intérêt de la France
et dans l'intérêt des Français dans un
esprit de responsabilité et parce que
notre taux de dépenses publiques en 2023
est supérieur de plus de 8 points à
celui de l'Allemagne et de 6 points à la
moyenne de la zone euro nous avons
proposé par un rendement de faire 20
milliards d'euros d'économie d'ici 2025
soit la sphère administrative le tout de
manière indolore pour les Français il
s'agissait non pas de supprimer des
services publics essentiels à nos
concitoyens mais de débutocratiser notre
pays en votant un grand plan de sobriété
bureaucratique l'esprit de ce plan de
sobriété bureaucratique c'est moins de
CERFA plus de services il s'agissait de
faire le tri dans les opérateurs de
l'État et de réviser les agences et
d'état celles qui font doublon par
exemple comme le Secrétariat à la mer il
s'agissait de réduire la masse salariale
des illustration centrale pour en finir
avec les lourdeurs administratives et la
bureaucratie tatión alors même alors
même qu'Emmanuel Macron lui-même
dénonçait en 2021 je le cite un état
bedonnant et malvoyant il s'agissait
enfin d'enrayer l'inflation d'hormiative
qui paralyse notre pays et ce chiffre en
milliards d'euros on élargissant le
principe d'une règle entente une règle
sortante à toutes les nouvelles normes
selon le CDE le coût des services
publics en France est supérieur de 84
milliards d'euros au coût moyen des
services publics dans le reste des pays
d'Europe pour finir je souhaite revenir
sur l'examen de la loi de programmation
en séance publique la majorité s'est
offusqué de la suppression des articles
16 et 23 qui concerne la trajectoire des
dépenses des collectivités mais c'est
quand même un comble que ce gouvernement
qui refuse de réduire le train de vie de
l'État impose aux collectivités locales
des efforts qu'ils ne s'appliquent pas
lui-même non monsieur le ministre quand
les dépenses des robes de près de 60
milliards d'euros en 2023 alors que la
dépense courante augmente de près de 30
milliards d'euros lors du précédent
quinquennat il ne peut être donné de
leçon à des communes à des départements
et des régions qui présentent un nez
après année des contes à l'équilibre
pour toutes ces raisons vous l'aurez
compris même si ce texte a été largement
des tricoté par l'Assemblée et les
républicains ils ont participé cela ne
suffit pas à modifier votre trajectoire
nous voterons donc contre ce projet de
loi de programmation mais parce que nous
sommes parfaitement raisonnables et
constructifs et au regard des contacts
déjà pris nous faisons entière confiance
au Sénat pour amender et réécrire
largement cette loi de programmation
afin de la rendre plus ambitieuse et
plus conforme pour l'intérêt de la
France et des Français je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Mohamed la
qu'il a pour le groupe démocrate
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
je veux d'abord m'adresser à tous ceux
qui doutent qui avait l'intention de
voter contre ce texte de le rejeter
arrêtons-nous un instant sur les réseaux
avancées ici et là pour rejeter ce texte
pourtant déterminant
outre un prétendument d'ambition
certains opposants arc nous ne voudrions
pas réduire le déficit structurel et
partant la dette publique
permettez-moi de vous confondre par des
arguments qui je l'espère vous feront
changer d'avis et voter pour ce texte
revenons un instant sur la période 2008
en raison de la crise des dettes
souveraines la France avait procédé à un
rééquilibrage budgétaire extrêmement
important notamment par de fortes
hausses des prélèvements obligatoires
pour les entreprises et surtout les
ménages tuant dans l’œuf la timide
reprise de l'économie européenne et avec
des conséquences désastreuses pour nos
finances publiques
chers collègues ne reproduisons pas les
erreurs du passé nous vous proposons une
stratégie à long terme
autre grande leçon tirées de cette
période
lors de la précédente crise la forte
hausse des dettes publiques de certains
pays de l'Union et l'absence d'un
mécanisme budgétaire commun avait
conduit à la crise des dettes
souveraines
pour limiter ce risque nous avons enfin
décidé de nous doter d'une faculté
budgétaire commune le plan de relance
européen financé par l'endettement
commun
notez chers collègues et rejet de ce
texte pourrait conduire à une remise en
cause des versements attendus du plan
national de relance et de résilience au
titre des années 2022-2023
soulignons aussi que notre objectif de
limitation de la hausse des dépenses
publiques à 0,6% volume soit quasiment
deux fois moins que la croissance
potentielle et le plus ambitieux depuis
la mise en place des lois de
programmation des finances publiques
j'en veux pour preuve les interventions
régulières du président concret pour en
dénoncer la prétendue austérité
d'autres prises de position encore plus
incohérentes à mon sens nous explique
que l'objectif de baisse des dépenses
n'est pas suffisant
ce que je peux tout à fait entendre mais
c'est sûr en même temps contre la
participation des collectivités à
l'effort de maîtrise des finances
publiques
vous considérez chers collègues de
droite
républicaines et que c'est à l'état de
sol de faire le travail je crois pouvoir
affirmer que la situation de l'État et
en partie dure en soutien sans faille
que nous apportons aux collectivités en
témoins la garantie de recettes mise en
place pour
2020 et 2021 qui a fait prendre en
charge à l'état des pertes de recettes
des collectivités dues au covid ou
encore le filet de sécurité qui viendra
en aide en 2022 et 2023 à celle
fragilisée par la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
les collectivités au même titre que les
autres administrations publiques doivent
participer à l'effort de redressement
des finances publiques et les modalités
proposées par ce texte était pour mon
groupe démocrate les bonnes
quant aux autres groupes
par de l'extrême ou des extrêmes vous
qui avez voté hier mais dans la main la
motion de censure du gouvernement dit
aux Français que sous couvert de lutte
contre l'austérité c'est en réalité
votre profondeurophobie qui vous anime
retenez ce proverbe chers collègues
c'est quand le ciel est bleu qu'on
répare le toit quand le ciel est bleu
qu'on répare le toit or avec plus de 110
points de dette en proportion du PIB si
nous voulons à l'avenir avoir des marges
de Manor budgétaires pour répondre à
d'éventuelles crises nous devons
maîtriser l'évolution des finances
publiques
plus encore ce texte propose des
dispositifs intéressants pour contenir
l'évolution de la dépense et de la dette
publique
évaluation plus poussée dispositif de
limitation dans le temps des dépenses
fiscales et des aides aux entreprises ou
encore une trajectoire claire des
baisses des dépenses brunes pour mieux
faire face à la dette climatique
pour pour toutes ces raisons objectives
responsables et protectrice de l'avenir
de nos concitoyens qui militent et nous
militons tous nous autres démocrates
nous votons pour ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue
la parole est un monsieur Christian
Baptiste pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues en juillet dernier dans
ce même hémicycle nous discutions du
programme de stabilité présenté par ce
même gouvernement et que poursuivait les
mêmes objectifs
rassurer les marchés rassurer la
Commission européenne rassurer la Cour
des comptes rassurer rassurer rassurer
justement à quel moment avons-nous prévu
de rassurer les Français et les
Françaises
nous le groupe socialiste est apparenté
sommes d'avril de constater qu'à défaut
d'adresser les questions d'urgence
sociale qui concerne directement les
Français cet assemblée se trouve
aujourd'hui mobilisée pour discuter de
texte qui est en train d'inutilité toute
relative en droit interne suite aux
annonces gandilocantes et dans
l'installation du Conseil national de la
refondation le selem on pouvait penser
qu'une nouvelle aire de dialogue et
d'écoute c'était ouverte entre le
gouvernement et les collectivités
territoriales néanmoins c'est avec
beaucoup de regrets que nous constatons
et nous avons eu à constater la posture
inverse
nous en voulons nous en voulons pour
preuve le contournement du sénème dans
la consultation est prévue par la loi
pour tout projet affectant les finances
des collectivités
ce n'est pas pour nous c'est pas nous
qui le disons mais bien le président de
la dite institution qui va jusqu'à
dénoncer et je cite un contournement
consternant des collectivités et ce
après la décision du gouvernement de ne
pas saisir cette instance sur le texte
que nous apprêtons que nous nous
apprêtons à voter et c'est sur la base
de cette analyse que fait marocain et
inédit de la Cinquième République ce
projet de loi nous le rejetons car elle
dessine une France privilégiée à la
rigueur budgétaire contre les besoins
des vestissement de notre de nos
territoire car vous le savez tout comme
nous les lois de programmation sont des
textes nos contraignants reposant sur
les hypothèses généralement optimistes
et rapidement obsolètes alors même que
leur objectif de se trouve que rarement
atteint
voyez-vous le gouvernement annuel à le
gouvernement actuel ne semble malgré
tout pas vouloir transiger avec cette
tradition d'optimisme qui se voudrait au
mieux volontariste au pire CCA a-t-il
d'exemple pour nous citer que les
hypothèses des cas de production en 2022
- 1,1 PIB potentiel d'une part et de
croissance potentielle d'autre part
1,35% par an de 2022 à 2027 sont
qualifiés d'optimisme par le Haut
Conseil lui-même puisque optimiste il
nous a permis de douter sur le sérieux
de leur fondement l'hypothèse de
croissance potentielle suppose des
effets hépatant immédiats des réformes
du RSA des retraites de la surchauffage
de l'apprentissage dont on ne connaît ni
les modalités ni l'impact ni même le
calendrier qui pourtant pour qui
pourtant produisent déjà les effets
miraculeux dans l'imaginaire du
gouvernement pour revenir sur le texte
lui-même le déplorons par exemple
l'absence totale de disposition concrète
destinée à adresser sérieusement la
planification de la transition
écologique or vous le savez certainement
la crise énergétique que nous
connaissons nous comment d'agir
rapidement et efficacement nous nous
devons d'être au rendez-vous d'être à la
hauteur des enjeux ne serait-ce que pour
garantir aux Français l'accès aux
énergies qui lui sont nécessaires dans
leur quotidien toujours sur ce texte
nous déplorons également que la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour 2023 soit au temps déconnecté de la
réalité que vit les collectivités
présentés comme ayant des supers
réserves vous estimez de manière
descendante sans aucune concertation
avec les collectivités que le mot que le
moment est venu de limiter les dépenses
de fonctionnement à titre d'exemple je
prendrai le cas des Antilles le
saviez-vous la Guadeloupe la Martinique
c'est Martin ou en considéré mais font
partie des îles les plus menacées par la
submersion marine dû au phénomène de
dérèglement climatique le saviez-vous
encore selon les rapports du GIEC d'ici
2040 certaines zones pourraient devenir
inhabitable pour vous le comprendrez
bien apparaît sur constance est posé une
baisse de dépenses de fonctionnement à
cette collectivité c'est compromettre
leur avenir sans qu'elle ne puisse se
douter de Moyer humain qualifiés pour
répondre à leurs préoccupations majeures
il est regrettable de le dire mais
suffisamment pour autant pour le
souligner la loi la programmation des
finances publiques telles que prise
entier fait totalement fidu contexte
économique à travers du concitoyens
déconnectés des spécificités donc c'est
tout naturellement que nous n'allons pas
voter ce ce texte merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame Lise manier pour
le groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques a fait l'objet d'un
examen attentif en séance publique
attentive ou plutôt abrasif puisque huit
articles ont été supprimés le texte sur
lequel nous sommes donc appelés à voter
dans quelques minutes a été fortement
dénaturé même si des avancées sont à
noter un meilleur bornage dans le temps
des dépenses fiscales une meilleure
évaluation de celle-ci le plafonnement
des taxes affectés et un état des lieux
d'émission et des emplois des opérateurs
de l'État plusieurs amendements adoptés
permettront également une meilleure
maîtrise évaluation de la dépense
publique et notamment fiscale la volonté
de créer une loi de programmation
plurielle des financements de la
transition écologique ou celle d'engager
une démarche de budget vert pour les
plus grandes collectivités territoriales
va également dans le bon sens nous ne
doutons pas que la navette parlementaire
permettra d'enrichir encore ce projet de
loi et surtout de rétablir les
dispositions supprimées pourtant
indispensables nous connaissons
l'attachement de nos collègues sénateurs
au sérieux budgétaire et à la bonne
gestion des finances publiques
car mes chers collègues une loi de
programmation des finances publiques si
elle n'a pas de portée contraignante sur
les lois de finances annuelles non
demeure pas moins un texte d'une grande
importance d'abord parce qu'elle nous
permet à nous parlementaires de mener à
bien notre rôle de contrôle et
d'évaluation de l'action du gouvernement
et des politiques publiques elles
fournit des outils comparatifs
indispensables au suivi de la politique
économique et à la gestion de nos
finances publiques ensuite parce qu'elle
fixe un cap une boussole que nous devons
suivre pour les cinq années à venir le
rétablissement des finances publiques
est une nécessité et pour y parvenir il
est indispensable que les objectifs
soient fixés dans le marbre de la loi
pour voir loin il nous faut un cap clair
et cohérent c'est ce que proposait cette
loi de programmation des finances
publiques et enfin parce qu'il en va de
notre crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires et acteurs extérieurs la
France a pris des engagements au niveau
européen qu'elle doit tenir la parole de
la France est quelque chose qui compte
et qui ne peut être bradée sur l’hôtel
de la politique politicienne au-delà
même de la parole donnée la fixation
d'une trajectoire est un gage de sérieux
vis-à-vis de nos créanciers des
investisseurs de tous les acteurs qui
pensent ils ont raison que la France est
un pays fort au fondamentaux solide et
doté d'une vision d'avenir car nous nous
montons pas le redressement des finances
publiques n'est pas un caprice de techno
ou une lubie dépassée c'est une absolue
nécessitée pour préserver notre
souveraineté et ne pas hypothéquer
l'avenir de nos enfants le mirage de
l'argent magique est terminé la remontée
des taux d'intérêts qui frôlent les 3%,
nous rappelle que notre pays ne peut se
permettre de vivre au-dessus de ses
moyens nous ne pouvons pas nous
soustraire à la réalité nous nous devons
pas être dans le déni nous ne pouvons
pas être le seul pays à se passer d'une
programmation sérieuse de nos finances
publiques nous ne devons pas être le
seul pays à laisser filer la dépense
publique et à considérer de dépenser
près de 60 milliards d'euros par an dans
la charge de la dette nous ne serons pas
le seul pays pour lequel une dette
publique de 3000 milliards d'euros ne
seraient pas un sujet mettre des
oeillères en nous privant d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nichera rien sauf à foncé vers le
précipice le pied sur l'accélérateur le
groupe Horizon est apparenté votre a en
faveur de ce projet de loi de
programmation pour les années 2023 2027
même s'il a été fortement à Moinerie car
nous sommes convaincus que la navette
parlementaire permettra d'aboutir à un
texte cohérent et structuré surtout le
plus dur et le plus important est devant
nous mettre en oeuvre la feuille de
route ainsi fixée il nous faudra faire
des choix courageux mener des référents
ambitieuses et justes et résister aux
sirènes de la facilité le groupe Horizon
est apparenté sera aux côtés du
gouvernement de façon responsable et
tout simplement car notre rôle est bien
celui d'assurer notre avenir et de
préserver notre souveraineté je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue
je vous indique que je fais annoncer le
scrutin dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale
la parole est à Madame Christine Arrighi
pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre chers collègue par ces temps de
49-3 successifs qui témoignent
insuffisance
intempestif a suffisance de l'incapacité
ou de l'absence de volonté du
gouvernement à prendre en compte le
choix électoral des Françaises et des
Français nous voilà à nouveau réunis
pour nous exprimer sur le projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
rappelons les éléments de langage du
gouvernement répété à l'envie espérance
en doute que par la répétition le
mensonge devient une vérité le mensonge
c'est celui d'une opposition qui serait
sans proposition une opposition de
blocage je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas une
opposition mais des oppositions cette
succession cette discussion m'offre
l'occasion de revenir au contraire sur
les nombreux amendements que la nupes
apporté en commission et ici même dans
cette assemblée afin d'améliorer ce
texte de programmation des finances
publiques au total les membres de
l'inter-groupe nups ont déposé 61
amendements dont 21 pour le groupe
écologiste non OPAC dit de confiance
maîtrise raisonnée des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités
accompagnement de l'investissement
durable
précision des dépenses non pilotables
des collectivités amélioration du ratio
pour dépenses considérées comme
défavorables ou favorables pour
l'environnement programmation du
financement de la transition écologique
ces mesures sont des mesures
raisonnables soutenues par de nombreux
élus responsables de tout bord telle est
la vérité mes chers collègues établis
preuve de la pluie je rappelle qu'en
démocratie gouvernait c'est aussi
écoutée surtout prendre en compte les
propositions faites dans l'intérêt du
pays notamment lorsqu'on se prévaut
d'adopter une nouvelle méthode de
dialogue le rejet du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
commission des finances et donc la
conséquence du refus de prise en compte
et des propositions de co-construction
venant des autres bords qui sont en
phase avec les besoins des collectivités
territoriales et des citoyens
face à la volonté du gouvernement d'une
réduction aveugle des déficits publics
nous avons proposé l'octroi de moyens
suffisants au financement des services
publics seul a même en ces temps de
crise qui se succèdent et se percute de
servi d'amortisseurs social pour les
plus précaires face aux souhaits de
baisser les dépenses de fonctionnement
des collectivités territoriales de 0,5
par en volume nous avons proposé une
baisse de 0,1 pour permettre aux
collectivités d'accélérer leurs
investissements en faveur de la
transition écologique énergétique afin
de limiter les dépenses énergétiques
réduire la consommation d'énergie
fossiles et atténuer les effets du
règlement climatique par opposition au
pacte dit de confiance du gouvernement
nous avons prôné la construction d'une
véritable relation de confiance qui
repose sur la reconnaissance pleine et
entière des collectivités comme racine
de la République c'est pourquoi en cette
période difficile pour les finances
publiques nous nous sommes opposés à la
suppression la CVAE mesure qui fait
perdre 8 milliards d'euros collectivités
territoriales
par cette décision nous marquons
également notre position la politique
fiscale de l'offre c'est le gouvernement
toujours
réinstallez dans le calme merci nous
disons donc encore une fois à Monsieur
Attal qu'après le quoi qu'il en coûte le
combien ça coûte pour l'écologie n'est
pas une question à se poser car se poser
cette question c'est nier l'urgence
sociale c'est nier l'urgence écologique
qui pourrait tout emporter par
l'effondrement des piliers de notre
existence même l'austérité budgétaire
serait-elle donc votre seule obsession
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat en bridant
les dépenses alors même que les besoins
sociaux énergétiques et écologiques sont
prégnants hier à Toulouse la température
est de
29,6 degrés la Garonne et l'Ariège sont
alors plus bas et tiaches depuis des
dizaines d'années nous avons proposé des
marges de manœuvre contribution de
solidarité sur les supers profits ISF
climatic progressivité de la taxation
des dividendes taxation des super
dividendes pour voter ici même vous les
avez toutes rejeté ces marges de
manœuvre
contrairement à vous nous souhaitons une
maîtrise du déficit et la dette publique
qui tiennent compte des difficultés
rencontrées par le pays avec des
investissements massifs pour éviter les
crises à venir transport logement
service public vous avez tout rejeté
face à votre politique d'assurance des
chocs qui consiste contre comme des
rustines à apporter de solutions
ponctuelles à des difficultés
structurelles nous portons une
ambitieuse politique de prévention et de
prospective qui passe par la
planification écologique le
développement des emplois verts la
sortie des énergies fossiles et la
justice sociale
gouverner c'est prévoir vous gouvernez
sans prévoir malgré les alertes qui se
font de plus en plus pressantes nous
voterons donc à nouveau contre cette loi
de programmation
je vous remercie
la parole est à Nicolas sangsue pour le
groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
le 24 avril dernier j'ai voté pour
Emmanuel Macron au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle je l'ai fait
non pas pour son projet non pas pour la
retraite à 65 ans non pas pour la
légende au marché libéralisé de
l'énergie qui fait tant de mal non pas
pour frapper durement les privés
d'emploi quand certains se gavent non je
l'ai fait tout simplement par amour de
la République par souci de faire vivre
nos valeurs communes quand les blés sont
sous la grêle fous qui fait le délicat
disait le poète en ces temps où la
guerre est à nos portes où les
nationalistes s'exacerbent poussant à la
haine à la division il faut bien
entendre messieurs les ministres que des
millions de Français comme moi comme les
députés de gauche dans cette hémicycle
on fait ce geste salutaire qui n'était
pas un geste adhésion et que notre main
n'a pas tremblé car elle ne tremble
jamais pour battre l'extrême droite dont
la haine c'est encore exprimée lors des
questions au Gouvernement cet après-midi
ce faisant le président de la République
n'a pas de majorité favorable à son
projet présidentiel et les Français ne
s'y sont pas trompés en nous lui
accordant pas de majorité absolue ici
dans cette émission alors toutes vos
circonvolutions vont redémontables
expliquant que le projet présidentiel
doit être déroulé coûte que coûte relève
plus de l'incantation qu'autre chose et
risque de se fracasser sur la colère et
la mobilisation sociale pour notre part
au cours de tous les débats budgétaires
avec tous les collègues du groupe de la
Gauche démocrate et républicaine
rassemblant les députés communistes et
des députés d'outre-mer nous n'avons
cessé de promouvoir un autre chemin pour
notre pays qui répond au Christ social
climatiques et démocratique alors que
les 500 plus grandes fortunes ont vu
leur patrimoine doubler en moins de
trois ans et que 10 millions de
personnes vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté il faut retrouver l'égalité par
un impôt plus juste plus progressif un
impôt qui s'attaque à la rente les
effets de l'inflation la perte de
pouvoir d'achat des couches modestes et
moyennes et par votre refus d'augmenter
les salaires de Louise pas seulement des
vies il pénalise notre économie
l'égalité c'est aussi redonner du
souffle à nos services publics à
commencer par la santé si malmenée avec
un nom d'âme qui baisse en nominal de
0,8%. il faut retrouver le chemin de la
liberté
libérons-nous du carcan imposé par les
traités européens de Maastricht et de
Lisbonne un carcan qui pèse sur les
peuples en portant un modèle
profondément injuste qui nous conduit à
lâcher notre souveraineté sur l'énergie
et place les citoyens les PME les
collectivités territoriales devant un
mur un modèle qui conduit à transférer
les richesses produites de plus en plus
vers la rémunération du capital il
retrouver le chemin de la fraternité
celui d'une France ouverte généreuse une
France qui aura compris que les
migrations conséquences directes de
guerre et de crise climatiques que le
capitalisme financier engendre nécessite
de l'humanité et non des barbelés si la
France saline sur les gouvernements
européens nationalistes d'extrême droite
elle perdra non seulement son âme elle
coupera le fil de son histoire la
précipitation a doublé de telles
gouvernement est une erreur monsieur le
ministre c'est en ayant en tête
l'exigence de portée au nos valeurs
communes de la République par des
politiques publiques ambitieuses
généreuses qui combattent un système
profondément inégalitaire que nous avons
débattu de la volonté d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
différentes personne ne peut accepter
que l'on assèche les services publics
comme cela est le cas dans la loi de
programmation que vous nous avez
présenté un seul exemple l'enseignement
scolaire dont le budget augmentera en
2023 mais qui en 2024 et 2025 en prenant
compte l'inflation personne ne peut
accepter une telle maltraitance faite à
l'assurance maladie qui oublierait le
financement du grand âge et attend
détruit la santé publique personne ne
peut accepter le sort fait au
collectivités territoriales ce que
toutes les associations d'élus communaut
ont dénoncé en continuant en serrer le
garrot financier qui les a se fixés
c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
même famélique doit être rejeté
l'urgence et de ne pas continuer dans
cette voie de l'échec qui risquerait
d'avoir commissue le pendant de ce qui
se passe en Italie ne soyez pas
messieurs les ministres les Mario Draghi
de ce côté des Alpes et c'est parce que
nous sommes responsables qu'avec tous
les groupes de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale nous
proposons un projet alternatif juste
efficace et porteur de jours heureux un
projet qui associe l'égalité pour tous
les territoires de la République en
hexagone comme un outre-mer je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Charles de
cours sont pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
je vais vous faire une confidence
notre groupe a hésité entre vote et pour
ou voter contre
votez pour présenter l'avantage de
contraindre le gouvernement à
transmettre au Sénat un texte vidé de sa
substance et si le Sénat avait de
l'humour il l'aurait voté conforme pour
faire respecter le vote de l'Assemblée
nationale
votez contre avait le mérite de la
clarté mais l'inconvénient de permettre
au gouvernement de saisir le Sénat de
son taxial mais je ne ferai pas durer le
suspente très longtemps par ce site
clarté pour maintenir la cohérence du
vote de notre groupe en commission et
lors des débats en séance publique nous
voterons contre ce texte en effet les
trois principales critiques que notre
groupe a adressé au projet de loi de
programmation 2023 2027 demeure même si
en commission commençait en public les
votes de l'opposition ont fortement
atténué le caractère négatif de ce texte
première critique concernant les
collectivités locales messieurs les
ministres vous persistez dans la dérive
jacobine ce texte comme le projet de loi
de finances est fondamentalement
contraire au principe fondateur de la
démocratie locale et en particulier de
la décentralisation en sommes vous êtes
des saturiens et nous nous sommes
toguiliens l'article 23 du projet de loi
abrogée en séance publique est un nouvel
avatar du pack de Cahors qui fut un
échec pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre
voulez-vous recréer une tutelle sur des
collectivités locales qui dégage
globalement un excédent de
fonctionnement leur permettant d'avoir
un taux d'autofinancement élevé et de ne
pas peser sur les déficits publics et
dont la dette publique locale représente
par rapport au parc faible moins de 10%
et déclinante et qui à la différence de
celle de l'État est exclusivement
affecté à l'investissement
ces textes poursuit également le
démantèlement de la fiscalité locale en
supprimant en deux ans au bloc communal
et au département la csvae composante
majoritaire de la CET qui s'était
substituée à Taxe Professionnelle cette
première réforme avait retiré au
collectivités locales le droit de fixer
le taux de la csva mais avait maintenu
la territorialisation de l'assiette
votre second réforme supprime la
thrillisation et poursuit le
démantèlement de la fiscalité locale il
ne reste pratiquement plus d'impôts
locaux pour les départements et les
régions dont les assemblées délibérantes
ont la possibilité de fixer les taux
pour le bloc communal il reste le
foncier bâti dont la pérennité
d'ailleurs peut-être éventuellement
menacée par le rapport le rapport une
nouvelle fois de la réforme de la sienne
deuxième critique vous réduisez des
impôts à crédit sans diminuer le taux
des prélèvements obligatoires dans la
durée et sans réduire les déficits
publics suffisamment rapidement est-il
sérieux messieurs les ministres de
supprimer en deux ans la CS VAE au coût
brut de 8 milliards de supprimer
l'ardevance audiovisuelle pour 3 et la
dernière tranche de la taxe d'habitation
pour 2 milliards 8 alors que les
déficits publics en 2023 sont maintenus
à 5%. le Haut Conseil prévoit d'ailleurs
un déficit public en 2022 inférieur aux
5% que vous annoncez mais un déficit
public en 2023 supérieur à 5% du fait
d’hypothèse trop optimiste sur les taux
d'intérêt à 10 ans de 25 - 2013 dans vos
prévisions 2023 pardon alors qu'on est à
2,7% début octobre 2022 sur le taux de
croissance 1% volume alors tes
prévisions se dégradent de moins en
moins pour atteindre entre 0 et 0,6% sur
le baril de pétrole 85 dollars que vous
avez retenu alors qu'on a dépassé les 90
et qu'on s'achemine vers 100 dollars du
fait de la position de l'OPE troisième
critique vous augmentez les dépenses
publiques d'une façon excessive sans
avoir le courage de faire des
économistes structurelles comme la
demander le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques votre affichage d'une baisse
en volume de 1 et demi pour des dépenses
publiques est une présentation
fallacieuse qui dissumine en fait une
augmentation de 0,7% si l'on utilise
l'indice implicite des prix du Bible et
dont l'indice les prix à la consommation
et si on élimine les effets des mesures
ponctuelles liées à la crise énergétique
vous dépensez 45 milliards en 2023 pour
limiter la hausse de l'électricité à 15%
comme pour les gaz et vous financez cet
énorme coûte par les reversements des
contrats à prix garantie des agir
renouvelables pour des milliards et pour
20 milliards par le versement des
entreprises énergétiques ce qui laisse
15 milliards net à financer dans le
budget de l'État mais messieurs les
ministres ces mesures sont des mesures
générales qui font baisser l'indice des
prix à la consommation de 3,2 points
mais une mesure courageuse consisterait
à concentrer les aides sur nos
concitoyens les plus en difficulté ce
qui serait plus juste socialement et
plus économe des deniers publics c'est
ce que nous vous avons d'ailleurs
proposé
dès le collectif de juillet 2022 en
conclusion notre groupe votre a contre
ce texte merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue
est-ce que je peux demander à
l'assistance de faire un peu silence
quand les orateurs s'expriment je sais
que c'est compliqué mais vous avez
encore un orateur monsieur Mathieu
Lefebvre pour le groupe Renaissance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs les
députés que n'a-t-on entendu sur cette
loi de programmation rarement une
trajectoire aura été autant combattue
mes chers collègues je voudrais vous
convaincre quand on la refusant et en la
vidant de sa substance économique non
seulement vous en vider le sens
politique mais surtout vous participez
de notre affaiblissement collectif de ce
point de vue au moins ce texte sera-t-il
permis de clarifier la répartition des
rôles qui nous animent avec d'un côté
celles et ceux qui refusent toute forme
de maîtrise de nos comptes publics et
celles et ceux qui considèrent que le
sérieux budgétaire a une valeur parce
que derrière chaque euro de dépenses il
y a soit un euro de dette soit un euro
d'impôt
le camp de la responsabilité donc d'un
côté et l'alliance des contraires au
service de l'anomie budgétaire de
l'autre et j'observe mes chers collègues
que nous avons aujourd'hui à la fois le
quoiqu'il en coûte et le quoi qu'il en
soit tous les prétextes est en bon pour
battre la majorité du président de la
République fusse au mépris de la
cohérence idéologique
majorité de circonstances quand la
droite et la gauche réunir rejettent
deux concerts l'évolution la plus
favorable de nos dépenses de santé
depuis 10 ans majorité de circonstances
quand la droite et la gauche rejette
tous les outils qui nous permettent de
maîtriser les dépenses de fonctionnement
de nos collectivités majorité de
circonstances quand la droite et la
gauche rejette l'idée même que nous
puissions poursuivre des objectifs
chiffrés de finances publiques
conformément à nos engagements européens
mais également au service de la
préservation de notre propre
souveraineté financière
mes chers collègues en proposant de
rejeter cette loi de programmation vous
avez listé à la fois notre pays en
Europe et votre propre rôle de
parlementaire en matière d'évaluation et
de contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
vous vous tirez une balle dans le pied
c'est d'ailleurs la première loi de
programmation à s'inscrire dans un cadre
rénové d'initiative parlementaire à
l'issue de l'excellent travail mené par
nos collègues Laurent Saint-Martin et
Eric Woerth à qui nous devons rendre
hommage
au fond
au fond que les parties extrêmes
rejettent ce texte parce qu'il considère
que la contrainte financière n'existe
pas que l'on peut s'endetter à l'infini
c'est assez cohérent avec leur ligne
politique quand on ne veut pas voir que
l'on est malade on ne prend pas sa
température mais j'en appelle au parti
de gouvernement si vous rejetez cette
loi vous cassez le thermomètre qui
pourrait nous servir collectivement de
cordes de rappel ça n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est un ancien ministre socialiste
Pierre Moscovici
un affaiblissement du Parlement d'une
part en rejetant cette loi vous allez
rejeter l'ensemble des prérogatives de
contrôle et d'évaluation de l'action du
gouvernement parce que la loi de
programmation c'est d'abord une boîte à
outils une boîte à outils à votre
service mes chers collègues refusez la
loi de programmation c'est refusé
d'admettre qu'il nous appartient
d'évaluer l'action publique sur la base
de revues annuelle de politique publique
comme le propose ce texte refuser la loi
de programmation c'est refusé de se
donner de la visibilité c'est refuser de
prévoir ce qui est je crois l'apanage de
législateur et en particulier du
législateur financier de ce point de vue
comment allez-vous faire mes chers
collègues sans loi de programmation pour
vérifier si le gouvernement tient ses
engagements comment allez-vous faire
pour vérifier si le gouvernement tient
ses engagements en matière de
verdissement des politiques publiques en
matière de réduction des dépenses
fiscales et sociales en matière de taxe
affectées sur quelle base allez-vous
vous fonder pour critiquer les
hypothèses macroéconomiques du
gouvernement quand vous n'aurez même
plus aucun texte pour le faire
mais plus grave encore mes chers
collègues se rejeter ce texte c'est nous
affaiblir collectivement et affaiblir le
président de la République en Europe que
l'on soit d'accord ou non avec lui que
l'on soit d'accord ou non avec lui vous
pouvez participer de son affaiblissement
mais vous nous entrainerez jamais dans
votre chute il ne faut pas être grand
grand clair pour se rendre compte de la
difficulté devant laquelle se trouverait
notre pays quand il serait la seule à ne
pas disposer d'une trajectoire qui crée
des millise latin de ses objectifs
financiers pire encore comme la rappeler
le ministre les bénéfices des aides
européennes pourraient être ralentis de
ce fait j'en appelle donc à la
responsabilité de tous les partis qui
croient dans cette belle idée d'Europe
et qui refuse d'affaiblir notre
souveraineté financière je le dis à nos
collègues socialistes
à vous qui avez transcrit le traité
européen dans notre droit interne et qui
avait présidé à la rénovation des lois
de programmation ne régnait pas renier
pas l'esprit de responsabilité qui un
temps vous animer encore et pire encore
je le dis à toutes celles et ceux qui
aspirent à gouverner notre pays un jour
vous pouvez dans le fond être en
désaccord total avec le projet de budget
mais la loi de programmation en votant
compte sur une bande de responsabilité
que vous faites sauter parce que un jour
si les Français vous ont donnent mandat
vous aurez à présenter au peuple une
nouvelle loi de programmation je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc je vais donc mettre au voile projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2023 à 2027
chacun a pu organiser sa place le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
[Applaudissements]
voici le résultat des scrutin beau temps
557 exprimé 552 majorité 277 pour 243
contre 309
lAssemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
monsieur le ministre vous avez demandé
la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés nous avons eu de
longs débats sur ce texte et je veux
remercier l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui se sont investis sur ces débats
remercier le président de la commission
des finances le rapporteur général du
budget Jean-René Cazeneuve c'est un
rejet qui était attendu puisque le texte
avait été rejeté en commission et que
donc c'était attendu qu'il soit rejeté
en séance publique je le dis et ça a été
dit par un certain nombre d'orateurs
avant moi des oppositions il aura une
forme de cohérence pour les oppositions
à laisser passer ce texte d'ailleurs
qu'elles l'ont méthodiquement
dénoyautées de l'intégralité de sa
substance au cours des débats mais vous
avez choisi de garder une cohérence qui
est celle de s'opposer absolument et
quoi qu'il en coûte au texte qui sont
présentés par le gouvernement c'est
dommage puisque ce texte prévoyait des
mesures importantes en matière
d'évaluation et de contrôle pour le
Parlement en matière de caducité dans
certains nombre de dispositifs et
d'évaluation renforcée pour le Parlement
et de choix ensuite la fin du Parlement
de prolonger ou non des dispositifs
finalement avec ce vote les oppositions
ont inventé le vote d'autocensure
puisqu'elle se prive d'instruments
absolument essentiels
pour évaluer l'action publique
le texte va continuer à cheminer au
Sénat et j'ai tout confiance dans les
sénateurs pour être capable d'adopter un
texte responsable responsable du point
de vue de nos finances publiques
responsables aussi du rôle des
parlementaires dans la capacité à
évaluer nos finances publiques merci à
tous merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la séance et suspendue pour 5 minutes et
nous continuerons sur le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale